i
i'm not sure if you're familiar with the
drake equation
that uh estimate i just did a video on
it yesterday because i wanted to give my
own estimate of it
it's uh it's an equation that combines a
bunch of factors to estimate how many
alien civilizations oh yeah i've heard
about it
yes so one one of the interesting
parameters you know it's like
how many stars are born every year
how many planets are on average per star
for this how many habitable planets are
there
and then the the one that starts being
really interesting
is uh the probability that life emerges
on a habitable planet so like
i don't know if you think about you
certainly think a lot about evolution
but do you think about the thing which
evolution doesn't describe which is like
the beginning of evolution the origin of
life
i think i put the probability of life
developing in a habitable planet one
percent
this is very scientifically uh rigorous
okay
first at a high level for the drake
equation what would you put that percent
that
on earth and in general do you have
something
do you have thoughts about how life
might have started
you know like the proteins being the
first kind of one of the early
jumping points yes so so i think
back in 2018 there was a very exciting
paper published in nature
where they found
one of the simplest amino acids glycine
in this in a comet dust
so so this is uh and i i i apologize if
i
uh don't pronounce it's a russian named
comets it's i think to grim of
gerasimenko
this is the comment where and there was
this uh
mission to to get and
get close to this comment and get the
the
stardust from from its tail and uh
when scientists analyzed it they
actually found
traces of uh you know uh
of glycine which you know makes up
you know the one it's one of the basic
uh one of the 20 basic
uh amino acids that makes up proteins
right so uh so that was that's exciting
very exciting right but you know it's
the question is very interesting right
so what uh you know what
if there is some alien life
is it going to be made of proteins right
or maybe
rnas right so we see that you know the
the rna
viruses are certainly you know
very well established sort of uh
you know group of molecular machines
right so um so yeah it's it's it's a
very interesting question
you know what what probability would you
put like how hard is this
job like i how unlikely just on earth do
you think this whole thing is
that we got going like is that are we
really lucky or is it inevitable like
what's your sense when you sit back and
think about
life on earth is it higher or lower than
one percent
well because one percent is pretty low
but it still is like damn that's pretty
good chance
yes it's it's a pretty good chance i
mean i i would
personally but again you know i'm um
you know probably not the best person to
to to do such estimations but
uh i would you know intuitively i would
probably put it lower but still i mean
you know
we're really lucky here on earth uh
i mean or the conditions are really good
it's me that's
you know i think that there was
everything was right
in the way right so so it's still it's
not the the conditions were not like
ideal if you try to to look at you know
what was you know several billions years
ago
when the life emerged so there is
something called
uh the rare earth hypothesis that you
know
encounter to the drake equation says
that
the you know the conditions of earth if
you actually were to describe
earth it's quite a special place
so special might be unique in our galaxy
and potentially
you know close to unique in the entire
universe like it's very difficult to
reconstruct those
same conditions and what the rare earth
hypothesis
argues is all those different conditions
are essential for life
and so that's the sort of the counter
you know like all the things we
you know thinking that earth is pretty
average i mean i can't really
i'm trying to remember to to go through
all of them but just the fact that it
um is shielded from
a lot of asteroids the obviously the
distance to the sun
but also the fact that it's um
it's like a perfect balance between the
amount of water
and land and all those kinds of things
and i don't know there's a bunch of
different factors that
i don't remember there's a long list but
it's fascinating to think about if
you're in order for something like
proteins and then dna and rna to emerge
you need um and basic living organisms
you need to be a very close and
earth-like planet
which would be sad or
exciting i don't know which uh if you
ask me i you know
in a way i put a parallel between um
you know between our own research
and i mean from the
from the intuitive perspective you know
you have those
two extremes and the reality is never
very rarely falls into the extremes it's
always the optimus always reached
somewhere in between so so i would
so and that's what i tend to think i
think that uh
you know we're probably somewhere in
between so they were
not unique unique but
again the chances are you know
reasonably small
the problem is we don't know the the
other extreme is like
i tend to think that we don't actually
understand the basic mechanisms of like
what this is all originated from
like it seems like we think of life as
this distinct thing maybe intelligence
is a distinct thing
maybe the physics that from which
planets and suns are born is a distinct
thing but that could be a very
it's like the stephen wolfram thing it's
like the from simple rules emerges
greater and greater complexity
so i you know i tend to believe that
just life finds a way
it like we don't know the extreme of how
common life
is because it could be life is like
everywhere like
like so everywhere that it's almost like
laughable
like that we're such idiots to think
where you like
it's it's like ridiculous to even like
think
it's like ants thinking that their
little colony
is the unique thing and everything else
doesn't exist
i mean it it's also very possible that
that's
that's the extreme and we're just not
able to maybe comprehend
the nature of that life
you